Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Du, ich fühle mich wie Maradona, weil ich seit Monaten aktiv im Fernsehen Fußball schaue und mich seit gestern als die Hand Gottes verstehe.
Und ich fühle mich wie Buddha, weil ich den ganzen Tag zu Hause rumsitze und nichts tue.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer dreihundertundsiebzig vom siebenundzwanzigsten November zwanzig zwanzig und wir sind wieder da und wir sind erleuchtet und wir sind äh uns unserer wahren Bestimmung bewusst geworden
Wir sind zu höherem geboren, Linus, das ist vollkommen klar. Ja, also ich spüre es überall.
Ich will's auch, äh dass ganz klar schwierig, dass eben.
So ein Moment der Erleuchtung, so ein kollektives Erwachen von irgendwie tonnenweisen, revolutionären. Hm.
Ich bin Jesus.
Du auch? Dachte, ich bin das.
Man merkt das auch wegen dem Bus am Ende, ne? Linus, Jesus.
Ach so, das ist ja so. Das habe ich ja noch jetzt, also klar.
Ja. Attila Hillmann ist Adolf Hitler und Linus ist Jesus.
Faktenlage ist einfach unbestechlich an dieser Stelle.
Ja. Ich habe, glaube ich, auch schon mal ein Tor mit der Hand erzielt.
Also als Torwart. Habe ihn reingelassen.
Abwurf in den Sturm werden, aber ging dann leider in die Hose. Tja, so ist das. Aber ist alles eine Frage der Interpretation. Ja, man man muss einfach nur die Dinge ausreichend,
Anders betrachten und schon geht's durch die Decke.
Ja und äh ne, du musst ja auch einfach so denken, ne, so think big, ja
Wenn wenn du irgendwie, ne, was die großen Leute die Welt verändert haben, ne, Mofas, Breakthings, Think Big oder sowas, ne?
Musst du halt schon irgendwie auch einfach mal zum Ziel haben mit zweiundzwanzig Jahren schon Schulen nach dir benannt zu.
Du machst Diana aus Kassel Schule.
Geht die erste Sophie äh die erste Sophie-Scholl-Schule hat sich umbenannt in die Jana aus Kasselschule.
Das wurde auch Zeit.
Ja, aber wir waren ja eigentlich, wir waren ja eigentlich hier bei äh Diego Maradona und das ist eine gute äh Überleitung zu unserer ersten Meldung diese Woche, glaube ich.
Und zwar ist es eigentlich ein Anschluss an unser Thema aus war das letztes.
Nee, vorletzte Saison, glaube ich.
Koks-Taxi.
Oder auch Grastaxi, ich weiß gar nicht, was hat er alles dabei gehabt.
Drogen, das waren Drogentaxi, also kein ähm also.
Koksack, sie ist ja auch nur so umgangssprachlich, ne? Genau. Ja und äh,
sich raus in Berlin wurde ein junger Mann äh angehalten, der hatte tatsächlich ähm Drogen an Bord und ist damit äh ganz offensichtlich herumgefahren, um selbige in irgendeiner Form zu verkaufen,
Und äh da wurde dann irgendwie kontrolliert und dann hatten sie irgendwie zweitausend Euro Bargeld gefunden und ein Kilogramm Marihuana. So
wahrscheinlich nicht sonderlich eine Nachricht wert gewesen, äh wenn er nicht auch noch einen Dienstausweis der Polizei dabei gehabt hätte, weil er halt zwar jetzt nicht unbedingt so,
eigentlich im Sinne Streifenpolizist ist, aber wohl in irgendeiner Form dort Mitarbeiter ist, also.
Also irgendwie.
Beim zentralen Service, wie das so schön heißt, Objekt, Schuss und Gefangen.
Ja Mitarbeiter beim Objektschutz, Botschaften, Regierungseinrichtungen oder gefährdete Objekte bewachen.
Ja. Alles klar. Also für der Job ist zwar langweilig, aber das glaubt dir keiner, dass das Kilogramm Gras irgendwie nur für dich war. Das ist ganz schön viel, oder? Ein Kilo?
Naja, ich meine, jetzt wurde die ganze Zeit als Objektschützer, musste vorm Reichstag äh stehen und dir diese ganzen Schwurbis anschauen und wenn du das ertragen willst, musst du wahrscheinlich so zugekifft sein, damit du dann in entsprechenden Grad an Entspannung noch an den Tag legen kannst.
Ja, da kommt er mit durch. In Berlin gilt das.
Mir auch klar, warum die Polizei so letargisch auf diese Schwurbel-Demos reagiert.
Doch alle bekifft.
Na ja, also äh auch hier mal wieder sehen wir, es ist irgendwie nicht so der die beste Idee ähm mit dem Drogenhandel.
Also wenn, dann muss man das schon sehr viel klüger anstellen.
Der hat ja also der hatte halt echt Pech, ne? Das war, glaube ich, eine allgemeine allgemeine Kontrolle, oder?
Das ähm Fahrzeugkontrolle heißt es hier, also ja, offensichtlich, einfach so. Aber ich meine, auch damit muss man rechnen.
Fahrzeug ja gut ja also.
Sollte man sich schon ein bisschen äh besser tarnen, wenn man so unterwegs ist. Ist halt nicht ohne Risiko so ein äh so ein Ding. So ist es.
Na ja, dann äh noch kurz in in eigener Sache ähm.
Wer ist denn großer ähm Kleidungsmagnet?
Wer ist denn großer, hier, ich komme mir vor wie Karl Lagerfeld, Tim. Ich komme mir vor wie Karl Lagerfeld Tim, weil wir haben jetzt gerade den online Verkauf von T-Shirts für die RC drei gestartet.
Ich fühle mich wie Karl Lagerfeld. Ähm genau, es gibt einen ähm also,
Es ist ja Pandemie, die vielleicht die Hörerinnen der ähm,
die diese Episoden irgendwann später hören, werden sich da ja nicht mehr dran erinnern, wann das genau war. Ähm genau, noch ist Pandemie und äh aus diesem Grunde verrichtet der ist der Chaos-Computerclub daran gehindert, einen Kongress in diesem Jahr auszurichten.
Und um sich nicht ganz so äh alleine zu fühlen und so,
überhaupt nichts zu tun zu haben zwischen den Jahren, äh richtet der Chaos-Computer-Club die Remote Caos Experience ein online Zusammensein, Experiment,
aus ähm mit also Talks und Workshops und sonstigen ähm um irgendwie hier diese.
Diesem geschehen in tristen einsamen Zeiten ein kleines bisschen äh Freude einzuhauchen. Da gibt es jetzt einen Ticketverkauf ähm,
Und zwar gibt es Tickets ab null Euro plus freiwillige Spender und ähm es gibt eben auch ein,
Merchverkauf, also T-Shirts mit den mit verschiedenen Logos der Veranstaltung und auch ähm was wir, glaube ich, sehr selten machen,
einfach nur CCC-Shirts, also es gibt den Chaos-Knoten als T-Shirt, es gibt das Pestörnchen als T-Shirt und es gibt den Tastaturstern als T-Shirt,
in diesem ähm Online-Shop, dieser Online-Shop wird ähm nicht vom
CCC betrieben, zwar haben wir einfach mal geguckt, was das so an,
Arbeit ist und an Zeitaufwand bedeutet, wenn man ähm paar tausend T-Shirts versendet,
haben dann eben festgestellt, dass es ja leider nicht damit getan ist, dass du einmalig, ne, eine Hau-Ruck-Aktion machst und Wochenende das alles versendest, sondern du musst ja dann dich auch um Retouren kümmern, Umtausch, ne, dann kommt irgendeiner
dir,
von drei bestellten Shirts nur eins zurück, dann musst du dieses Splitbuchungen machen und so, das ist alles eine äh so großer Aufwand, der sich über so eine lange Zeit zieht, ne.
Dass wir uns da jetzt von einem ähm Fullfilm,
Team helfen lassen, die diesen ähm Shop für uns betreiben und die sich alle Mühe geben, dafür zu sorgen, dass äh die Ware hoffentlich sogar noch bis Weihnachten,
ankommt, allerdings ähm bei der aktuellen Überlastungssituation im Transportwesen äh können wir das leider jetzt schon nicht mehr garantieren. Aber wenn, wer sich für ein CCC-Shirt interessiert, kann da bis zum sechsten zwölften,
garantiert bestellen und das deswegen sag ich das überhaupt hier, weil es soll ähm ein Vorverkauf war zu Kongresszeiten auch immer ein großer Wunsch,
weil ähm durch eine durch eine Vorbestellung quasi sichergestellt wird, dass dieses T-Shirt tatsächlich produziert wird und auch lieferbar ist. Und äh das ist hier der Fall. Und das geht bis zum sechsten Dezember. Wer also bis zum sechsten Dezember bestellt,
wird,
Diese Bestellung auf jeden Fall bekommen, ganz ohne Schlange stehen und äh sonstige äh Stimmungsbremse, weil zwanzig zwanzig ist ja Stimmungsbremse genug.
Gibt's auch einen RC drei. Ich war nicht dabei, Shirt. Ja, ach ja, es ist alles ein bisschen traurig, ne.
Es ist, es ist traurig, aber ähm,
Es ist das Beste, was wir haben, ne. Und müssen irgendwie versuchen, das Beste draus zu machen. Ich habe übrigens gesehen, in die in die in die Tiefpunkte von zwanzig zwanzig reiht sich auch ein Song von Scooter ein. Fakt twenty twenty,
wo wo hier in in besten Denglish sich über das Jahr beklagt, aber das ist auch wirklich ähm.
Ja gut, aber der hat sich ja auch schon in anderen Jahren in die Tiefpunkte eingereiht. Von daher macht das jetzt keinen großen Unterschied.
Aber das nochmal ein besonderer Tiefpunkt. Na ja ähm da hoffen wir vielleicht mit ein bisschen Videostreams und Workshops und online Konferenzen, was besseres auf die Beine zu stellen.
Das Ding heißt ja auch Chaos Experience. Da kann man vielleicht auch nochmal was zu sagen, weil das Wort Chaos ist natürlich ähm einerseits ein sehr generischer Begriff äh so in unseren Kreisen
Hat aber auch nochmal so eine spezielle Note und zwar als das Chaos bezeichnet man gemeinhin auch die Community als solche. Also, wenn man,
so von allen spricht, wenn man so alle Leute, die sich dem so anschließen, nicht Vereinsmitglieder oder so, sondern die Leute, die einfach auch
Das jährliche Treiben, sei es jetzt auf den Veranstaltungen oder eben auch online in irgendeiner Form,
prägen, mitgestalten, Teil sind, Leute, die man kennt. Dieses Netzwerk einfach. Und das ist so das Chaos. Und ich glaube,
So sollte man diesen Begriff verstehen. Es ist nicht der Kongress, sondern es ist äh eine eine äh eine Beteiligungsoption für das Chaos, um,
den Teil zu also ersetzen ist vielleicht auch schon unter hochzugriffen oder zumindest hier so eine Art ähm Alternative anzubieten,
um diesen Netzwerkfaktor, dieses, wir sind halt dann auch irgendwo eine Gemeinschaft, denen in irgendeiner Form äh was anzubieten, um die Auswirkungen abzufedern.
Das äh ist sehr äh das erfasst es sehr sehr also ein ein Online-Community-Event. Ja und ähm.
Äh das wird also das wird
sicherlich sehr schön, aber das wird selbstverständlich äh wer auch immer sich anschickt, da einen Vergleich zum Kongress zu machen, hat sich,
ein Weg voller Tränen natürlich ausgesucht, weil das das alles abzubilden ähm und daran ran ranzureichen, das geht halt einfach nicht. Das haben viele Online-Events,
ähm dieses Jahr bewiesen, dass sie nicht an an ihr äh Präsenzpendant anknüpfen können. Aber, und das denke ich da, dieser Vergleich ist schon der richtige, zu überlegen so,
Was ist ein Online-Event und in dieser Reihe denke ich, kann sich das dann hoffentlich sehr wohl, sehr gut sehen lassen, was das Chaos da für sich ähm kredenzt,
Jo, Tim, es gibt Neuigkeiten von der Schufa.
Ja, auch echt.
Die sind es supergeil. Also ich also die Schufa
Die Schufa ist ja ähm eine Auskunft Thai, die ihren ähm ihren Wertbeitrag zu unserer Gesellschaft darin beschreibt, dass sie Leute, die schon mal Schulden gemacht haben, davor schützt noch mehr Schulden zu machen, ja? Ähm,
das so ihre, ihre Selbst äh Auffassung, ne, also.
Zu unserem Schutz.
Die fühlt sich quasi wie, was weiß ich, Karl Marx, ja? Und.
Und ähm.
Um einfach die Auswirkung des bösen Kapitalismus abzufedern.
Genau, genau, ja, ne, so.
Mhm.
Und ähm jetzt ähm.
Ist natürlich das, also kennen wir, also sie sie haben Daten von irgendwie äh sieben siebenundsechzig, achtundsechzig Millionen Menschen,
Und aus denen errechnen sie ja, wie wir wissen, intransparent einen Score, der dann eben am Ende darüber entscheidet, ob du jetzt zum Beispiel einen Kredit kriegst oder nicht. Und wenn du den nicht kriegst
ja? Oder den oder Kreditvertrag geht das ja auch um Handyverträge und so großes Thema, ne? Wenn du den nicht kriegst, dann sagen die dir ja nicht, woran es liegt,
Ne? Du kannst dir das potenziell denken, aber wir haben ja hier auch schon mal, glaube ich, vor ein paar Jahren mit
mit Stefan Urbach gesprochen, der da äh Beispiele genannt hatte, äh ähm wo er überhaupt nichts mit zu tun hatte, ne, aber weil er sich in dem Themenfeld auskennt, dann in der Lage war, das zu bereinigen durch Widersprüche und so. Aber wir es gibt eine.
Nennenswerte Anzahl Menschen, die unter einem schlechten Schufa-Score leiden und denen kein Weg gezeigt wird, den wieder zu verbessern, ja?
Und da hat sich die hat sich die Schufa gedacht, hm vielleicht können wir daraus ja was machen, ja? Und ähm jetzt haben die gesagt, pass auf, gar kein Thema,
wenn du einen schlechten score hast,
dann erpressen wir von den Leuten einfach mehr Daten. Also, wenn du sagst, ich habe einen schlechten Scoren, sagt die Schufa, naja, du kannst uns ja mal äh deine kompletten Kontozugänge geben, dass wir da ein bisschen mehr Daten sammeln können,
Dann überlegen wir uns nochmal, ob wir dir vielleicht einen besseren Score geben. Vielleicht.
Aber auch nicht, ja? Und da diese Daten werden aber nur zweckgebunden verarbeitet und nur kurz gespeichert und dann gibt's noch eine zweite Ebene, wo du den äh das dauerhaft äh ähm,
quasi genehmigt, dass sie diese deine Kontoauszüge speichern und für ihre Dienste als Auskunft teil ähm,
auswerten dürfen. Das Ganze nennt sich Schufa Check Now und ist natürlich eine total geile Idee, einfach noch mehr Daten zu sammeln, ne? Und das halt von den Leuten, wenn du denkst so, hm, was können wir den Leuten anbieten, damit die uns Daten geben,
ja eigentlich nichts, niemand mag uns, naja dann geben, dann bieten wir denen an, dass wenn sie uns mehr Daten geben, dass wir potenziell ihnen besseren Score geben,
Sind die eigentlich noch zu retten?
Das sind so die freundlichen Herren, die so in den Laden so reinkommen. Ja, also, sie haben hier Probleme. Könnten wir ihnen vielleicht mal helfen? Und sonst hätten sie ja vielleicht noch mehr Probleme dann, wenn wir das nicht tun.
Schönes Geschäft haben sie hier. Das wäre aber doch echt schade,
Ja, total. Also ähm.
Das ist also jetzt gerade irgendwie ein Pilotprojekt. Sie haben da irgendwie so einen Test ausgerollt mit o2 oder so und sagen äh wir sind gerade in einem Test von Schufa-Check Now
über die spätere Ausgestaltung des finalen Produktes können wir derzeit noch keine Auskunft geben, wurde aufgedeckt von Tagesschau investigativ, aber,
Meine Güte, ich find's wirklich unterhaltsam.
Ja, ich meine so, ich will ihnen jetzt nicht unterstellen, dass sie nur nur schlechte Ziele haben. Es ist natürlich wirklich ein schwieriges Thema, ne. Aber so diese Aussage von, ja, sie haben einen total schlechten Score. Ja, warum? Ja, wissen wir auch nicht.
Können wir uns ja mal Ihre Daten anschauen, dass wir mal sagen können, warum wir überhaupt so eine schlechte Meinung von Ihnen haben?
Also du musst ja mal es also der der genau, vielleicht geben sie uns mal mehr Daten, dass wir nochmal gucken, ob.
Erstmal wissen, warum.
Das Entscheidende wäre, dass die vernünftig erklären, was wo, ne, dass dass die ihren,
ihr Dingen da transparent machen und sagen, okay, so und so kannst du das und das Problem musst du uns von überzeugen, dass es gelöst ist, damit wir dich wieder besser bewerten, ne? Das ist ja der,
Der entscheidende Punkt, aber sie sagen ja immer, ja, wenn wir das machen, dann wird der Algorithmus gegamt. Aber okay, ich will jetzt keine lange Schufa-Debatte führen, finde es nur sehr äh äh unterhaltsam, was sie da für ein schönes Geschäftsmodell gefunden haben.
Kostet das dann auch noch was?
Nee, soweit ich weiß nicht. Also du hast ja den also außerhalb deine kompletten Kontoumsätze in deren Händen kostet das nichts. Nee. Musst du auch nochmal sehen, ne? Eigentlich recht großzügig.
Vor allem da danach äh kriegst du halt unter Umständen noch schlechteren Score und kannst dann überhaupt nichts mehr dagegen machen. So, das ist ja äh.
Also das ist ja, das ist ein äh Schloss ohne Boden. Wir waren aber ja eigentlich hier noch bei äh Kokstaxis und Diego Maradona.
Da ist natürlich ein Problem,
dass auch, also wer wird hier gerade heute hier am Black Friday sehr viel darüber diskutiert, dass der, dass der Einzelhandel Schwierigkeiten hat und der Online-Handel weniger, ne? Und äh das ist natürlich auch beim Drogenhandeln,
ein Problem, dass es das hier die Online-Plattform, die Marktriesen, ja,
im Internet fungieren und wir haben da vor einigen Monaten schon drüber gesprochen, dass das Justizministerium plant, jetzt mal endlich,
diese Online-Marktplätze illegal zu machen, ja? Und da gab es eben ähm in diesem Gesetzesentwurf, in dem ersten so ein Passus, der im Prinzip auch unter Strafe stellte.
Anbieten von ähm Produkten und Dienstleistungen, die,
den Zugang zu illegalem.
Vereinfachen. Ich erinnere mich jetzt nicht mehr an die genaue Formulierung, aber letztendlich wäre das gegen so etwas gegangen wie,
den Betrieb von Tornotes, weil der Drogenhandel als Tor-Hind-Service angeboten wird. Oder angeboten werden kann oder dass äh ähm das Betreiben von VPN, die ähm,
eventuell auch von Leuten genutzt werden, die damit,
ähm Urheberrechtsverletzungen begehen. Ja, also so dieses, dass man wirklich dann auch auf die Infrastruktur wollte, ne? Und sagt so,
wir potenziell verbieten wir deine Autobahn, wenn da irgendwie ein Kokstaxi drüber fährt oder so, ne? Und das hat natürlich relativ viel Kritik gegeben und jetzt gibt's einen, also einen Teilerfolg, dass sie jetzt wenigstens.
Diesen ähm Teil, der die Infrastruktur bedroht, rausgeschmissen haben und jetzt einen Paragraph Paragraph,
hundertsiebenundzwanzig STGB haben wollen, der sinngemäß lautet, wer eine Handelsplattform im Internet betreibt, der einen Zweck darauf ausgerichtet ist, die Begehung von rechtswidrigen Taten zu ermöglichen oder zu fördern, wird mit Freiheitsstrafe bis zu fünf Jahren oder mit Geldstrafe bestraft.
Ähm.
Erfasst allerdings auch so etwas wie ein Forum, weil unter Handel fallen auch Kaufgeschäfte, Tauschgeschäfte oder Schenkungen. Ähm das heißt, das könnte jetzt potenziell meine heißgeliebten Hackerforen ähm bedrohen.
Weil das eben im weitesten Sinne ähm Handelsplattformen sind, die ja die Begehung von rechtswidrigen Taten,
ermöglichen oder fördern, ja? Also da ist die Kuh nicht wirklich vom Eis, aber ähm,
immerhin wird nicht direkt die Infrastruktur angegriffen. Ich denke, das hat auch damit zu tun, dass die Justizministerin jetzt auch gelernt hat, dass ähm.
Ja, dass dass im Prinzip der größere Teil offenbar in irgendwelchen Telegram-Kanälen abläuft, ne? Und da macht's halt dann wenig spätestens da wird's äh schlecht mit dem Angriff auf die,
Infrastruktur.
Außerdem in dem Gesetz Staatstrojaner und Onlinedurchsuchung bei solchen Ermittlungsverfahren, also wie gesagt, die Kuh ist nicht vom Eis, das ist nach wie vor ähm kein besonders ähm,
kein Gesetz, das nicht sehr weitreichende Grundrechtseinschränkungen auch äh,
erlaubt in dem Strafverfahren oder in dem Ermittlungsverfahren, aber immerhin äh kann man weiterhin Anonymisierungsdienste anbieten,
ohne sich diesen Risiko auszusetzen.
Ja. Mir ist gar nicht so hundertprozentig klar, wo jetzt eigentlich so das Problem bisher war, dass sie da nicht weiter.
Nicht. Es gibt kein Problem. Es gibt tatsächlich kein Problem. Also dieser ähm Gesetzesentwurf wurde von ähm Andre Meister veröffentlicht bei Netz Politik Org. Ähm,
und der schreibt da auch noch einmal äh die Reihe an online,
Drogenhandelsplätzen, die äh von der Polizei platt gemacht wurden, ne, Wallstreet Market, Walhalla, Deep dot Web und das ist jedes Mal.
Wenn es so einen großen Darknet,
den Daten mit Markt gibt, dass die Betreiber vor Gericht landen insbesondere in Deutschland hier dieser Fall mit dem Wallstreet Market, den wir hier auch schon mal besprochen hatten, wo es auch diese Folge,
gibt, bei der ich äh mitwirken durfte und so, ja? Und ähm,
Andre, ich zitiere jetzt einfach mal andere. Die Bundesregierung will die Rechtslage trotzdem verschärfen. Im Koalitionsvertrag hat sie vereinbart eine Strafbarkeit für das Betreiben krimineller Infrastrukturen einzuführen. Und das ist jetzt im Prinzip,
diese Koalitionsvertragsverbindlichkeit möchte das Justizministerium jetzt ähm ein einlösen.
Andre, braver Journalist, wie er ist, sagt auch das ursprünglich die erste Berichterstattung beim Spiegel war. Deswegen verlinken wir den natürlich auch nochmal hier bei uns in den.
Aber ja, also von der, wenn man sich jetzt anschaut, was die Erfolge der Strafverfolgung angeht und der Strafbarkeit äh sehe ich hier auf jeden Fall keinerlei äh Lücke in der in den Gesetzen, weil,
man ja immer diese Betreiber äh und Betreiberinnen, wenn es welche wären unter Beihilfe kriegt,
für die Straftaten. Insofern das ist ähm,
grundsätzlich glaube ich nicht, dass hier ein ein Bedarf besteht, dass da legislativ was entsteht.
Tatsächlich sagen. Wenn man sich anschaut, welchen Erfolg ähm die Strafverfolgungsbehörden in dem Bereich haben, weltweit übrigens, ja.
Da hast du total Recht.
Ja. Was man auch noch äh verbieten könnte, ist das Veröffentlichen von Zugangsdaten äh auf auf öffentlichen Kanälen.
Ist das peinlich?
Von äh geheimen oder sagen wir mal nicht so vielleicht geheim, aber geschlossenen Online-Meetings,
Das äh ist ja ein generelles Problem jetzt, wo sich alle online treffen. Muss man nicht mehr durch die Security äh eines äh einer kompletten Behörde durch, sondern man muss sozusagen nur noch durch die Security eines Videokonferenzanbieters durch,
Und das äh ist so ein bisschen schiefgelaufen bei den EU Verteidigungsministern. Da hat nämlich die niederländische Verteidigungsministerin Ank
Bill. Ohje. Beile Welt, ne, heißt das doch, glaube ich, ne. Ich bin leider das holländische eingeschränkt äh mächtig.
Beide Welt würde ich das aussprech.
Okay, gut, ich habe da.
Beide Felds sogar.
Oder Feld, genau. Hatte äh sie hatte über äh Twitter nämlich ein Foto von ihrer,
Teilnahme an diesem äh Onlinetreffen veröffentlicht und äh auf diesem Foto waren dann fünf der sechs erforderlichen Ziffern äh erforderlich äh zu sehen, die halt erforderlich waren.
Um an diesem Treffen selber teilzunehmen,
und na ja, wenn halt nur noch eine Ziffer fehlt, äh stehen da nicht so viele zur Auswahl. Kann man einfach mal durch äh probieren und das,
führte dann dazu, dass ein Journalist sich dann einfach direkt mal in diese Konferenz mit reingesetzt hat zum großen Hallo von allen Beteiligten, die nie schlecht geguckt haben. Hat auch nicht viel böses gemacht, hat nur gesagt, ja hallo, hier äh
bin jetzt bald dabei. Ich gehe auch gleich wieder. Keine Angst. Aber ihr scheint da wohl offensichtlich ein kleines Problem äh zu haben.
Das dann auch gleich noch gefilmt und veröffentlicht.
Das sind die, das sind die Leute, die äh uns die Verschlüsselung wegnehmen wollen, weißt du?
Irgendwelche Zoom-Calls.
Ja und die auch so mit hochgeheimen äh,
Sachen spielen. Wenn er sie wenn er sich der sozusagen jetzt einer nur mit so einem Testbild eingeloggt hätte,
ja, ohne sich selber in der Kamera zu zeigen, sondern nur so ein Zoom-Logo oder so, hätte keiner gemerkt.
Natürlich nicht. Total stark.
So sind sie, unsere Verteidigungsminister.
Na ja, dann äh hatten wir auch in der letzten, das war, glaube ich, die letzte Sendung, wo wir darüber berichtet haben, dass äh ihr mehrere,
Bundesländer meinen, man müsste jetzt endlich wieder die Vorratsdatenspeicherung einführen und ich habe gesagt, dass das mehrmals,
jetzt geurteilt wurde, dass das verfassungswidrig ist, ähm,
und da gibt's ein äh Gutachten des wissenschaftlichen Dienstes des Bundestags und die sagen ja ein deutsches Gesetz zuvor Ortsdatenspeicherung vor dem Europäischen Gerichtshof,
kein Bestand haben. Ja, das das sagen also äh die in diesem Bericht äh steht drin, der EuGH hielt,
in den beiden neuen Urteilen an seiner oben dargestellten bisherigen Linie fest, dass grundsätzlich eine allgemeine und unterschiedslose Speicherungs- beziehungsweise Weiterleitungspflicht von Verkehrs und Standortdaten,
für private TK-Anbieter mit dem Unionsrecht unvereinbar sei, da sich der Eingriff in die entsprechenden Grundrechte nicht auf das absolut notwendige Beschränke.
Danach dürfte die deutsche Regulierung von zwanzig fünfzehn kaum Bestand haben, denen sie sie zwar kürzere Speicherfristen vor, aber die Speicherung soll immer noch ohne gesonderten Anlass erfolgen, was den oben genannten Grundsätzen des EuGH nicht,
entspricht, ja? Finde ich schön, ähm das wurde ähm jetzt,
Also ähm im November erst abgeschlossen und da haben wir jetzt nochmal, ne, also wenn wir jetzt hier in, im Bundestag noch irgendwelche Bemühungen wieder sehen, äh in Richtung Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Ähm,
kann man wirklich sagen, so hier, ihr habt einen wissenschaftlichen Dienst, damit ihr euch diese Sachen erklärt, ja? Das hätte ich denen auch erklären können, aber mir glauben die ja nicht, jetzt haben die da den wissenschaftlichen Dienst mit bemüht. Ähm vielleicht hören sie darauf, aber,
Das ist wirklich,
Also es ist gut, dass dass sie noch, wenigstens haben sie gefragt, wenigstens haben sie gefragt, Tim und sie haben jetzt auch eine Antwort bekommen. Hoffentlich merken sie sich die Antwort. Vielleicht verstehen sie die auch, wenn sie die nochmal erklärt haben möchten, können sie einfach noch ein Gutachten in.
Soll ich einen Tipp abgeben?
Ja, das äh können wir uns glaube ich also da können wir uns schon mal fest drauf einstellen, so nächstes Jahr gibt's wieder irgendwie einen,
Politiker von Dollar Partei fordert äh Forstdatenspeicherung wegen Dollar Vorfall.
Ja, unglaublich. Und ähm weiteres Problem, was wir eben auch für.
Ähm also was schwere Grundrechtseinschränkungen mit sich bringt und damit äh auch natürlich in der Gefahr ist, nicht verfassungsgemäß zu sein, sind äh Gesetze zur,
Zum Staatstrojaner und die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte hat jetzt äh am Montag am Bundesverfassungsgericht eine Verfassungsbeschwerde ähm
eingelegt gegen,
Die Staatstrojanergesetzgebung des Landes Hamburg. Ähm außerdem in Hamburg, die machen eine Art digitale Rasterfahndung, also automatisierte Datenauswertung,
und die ähm GFF hat da jetzt also Rechtsanwältinnen und Aktivistinnen und Journalistinnen äh gefunden,
mit denen sie dagegen klagt, weil diese eben von diesem von dieser Maßnahme oder von diesen Maßnahmen potenziell ebenfalls äh betroffen sind.
Und äh kann man ihn natürlich auch nur wünschen, dass sie hier äh Erfolg haben mit der Verfassungsbeschwerde gegen weitere Grundrechtseinschränkungen.
Auf jeden Fall immer sehr fleißig die.
Damit sind wir dann jetzt auch schon am Ende dieser sehr kurzen Sendung. Ich komme mir schon vor wie eine Telefonzelle, ne. Fasse dich kurz. Ich fühle mich schon wie eine Telefonzelle. Und.
Ja, ungewohnt, ne?
Im Himmel. Ja und ich möchte danken in diesen ähm harten Zeiten. Sabine, Werner und Oliver, vielen herzlichen Dank.
Ja und vielen Dank an alle Unterstützer von Logbuch, Netzpolitik, das war's für diese Woche. Mal gucken, nächste Woche haben wir dann vielleicht ein bisschen mehr zu erzählen.
Gibt's wieder mehr Dystopie.
Ja, jetzt, dass der Bonustrack ist ja auch äh jetzt nicht unbedingt besonders äh utopisch, ne?
Fällt ja jetzt auch aus, wollen wir dann auch noch eine Weihnachtssendung machen,
Das wäre doch mal was Neues, so.
Glühwein im Stream oder so. Hallo Jim. Harry,
bei dir sind mehr als fünf Leute.
In unserem Bundesland ist das erlaubt.
Wie viele dürfen wir?
Keine Ahnung, weiß nicht.
Also auf jeden Fall mehr als ich an Weihnachten irgendwo sitzen haben will. Das kann ich dir sagen.
Bei mir kommt keiner rein.
Das war ja auch so schön so wunderbar deutsch, ne?
Diese Diskussion über dieses diese Werte
Wollt ihr dann bei mir in die Wohnung kommen, wieviel der Staat hat nichts damit, dass ich habe mir diese Debatte, also diese äh Regierungserklärung angeschaut, wie Angela Merkel das äh im Bundestag erzählt und danach diese,
mir dreht sich alles, wenn diese dann da irgendwie ihre ihren,
Oh, die ist so schlecht gelaunt und die arme Frau, ey, der muss echt mal jemand helfen. Alice Weidel.
Wer? Ach so, ja.
Ey und die Bea Beatrix äh von von Storch sitzt dann da und pöbelt die ganze Zeit dazwischen und du denkst dir so, ey Leute,
Leute, so ein bisschen, ich meine, es muss jetzt nicht jeder hier wie so eine Hippie durchs durch die Welt rennen und den ganzen Tag gute Laune haben, ne. Aber auch so ein bisschen,
positives Charisma und bisschen Kultur mal an den Tag legen, ne? Aber nein, aber nein.
Völlig das das macht mich auch so ein bisschen irre. Die sind alle so furchtbar vergrämt. Und die haben einfach keinen Spaß. Und die können überhaupt nicht lachen. Auch diese ganzen Schwubler sind alles freudlose Menschen.
Du möchtest eigentlich hingehen und dir in den Arm nehmen, ne, aber darfst halten, ich muss Abstand halten.
Kommt so eine Pandemie ganz recht.
Aber was, ne, genau, ne? Und dann diese deutsche Diskussion, die einen dann so,
Ah, jetzt äh wollte er mir, da ihr könnt gar nicht nennen, nee, nee, nee, meine Wohnung kommt eh nicht rein. Und dann irgendwie so, oh nein, oh nein, oh nein, der Block, was der Block, was kommt jetzt? Und du denkst dir wirklich so, Alter, das,
jetzt weißt du, du bist in Deutschland, ne? Wenn man sich nur noch darüber aufregt, was der Staat sich rausnimmt oder was der Blogwart will und statt einfach mal so zu überlegen so, hm, vielleicht haben die sich da was bei gedacht, hm,
wollen wir nächstes Jahr auch noch mit Oma äh äh Weihnachten feiern oder laden wir die ein?
Ne? Oder hören wir zum Beispiel hier auf den Wasser Helge Braun hat ja dann so gesagt Leute dann kriegt er ein paar Tage vorher Schulferien, dann könnt ihr euch isolieren, damit ihr und und nochmal auf Symptome prüfen bevor ihr irgendwie Heiligabend um meinen Arm nehmt, ne? Aber das sind alles nur die Bösen,
Tim. Alter, das ist so so deutsch, ey.
Ciao. Mein Tipp ist, bleibt,
bleibt einfach allen fern irgendwie. Ich meine jetzt mit der Weihnachtsregelung, da wird's dann halt leider tja, leider nicht besser werden, von daher werden wir den ganzen Scheiß noch so locker bis äh Ende Februar, März äh weitermachen müssen, also.
Leider nicht viel dran ändern. Ist schade, aber.
Ja und das ist auch für es ist wirklich Scheiße, ich gebe bisher zu, aber es wird nicht dadurch besser, dass man Beatrix von Storch äh die die Situation bewerten lässt. Äh der ist noch nie eine Situation von besser geworden.
Nichts wird besser durch Beatrix von Storch.
Jetzt haben wir auch ehrlich einen Sendungstil. So, jetzt können wir aufhören. Okay, tschüss.
Tschüss.